très heureux d'une part parce que c'est
le résultat d'un travail pendant un
certain nombre d'années une équipe
renouvelée sur moi un très bon projet
puisque dans la période actuelle
alors qu'on a vu qu'il y avait quand
même un gros taux d'abstention dans les
beaunois continue de faire confiance
puisque malgré un vote bien inférieur à
celui du premier tour ont réussi à faire
un score meilleur qu'au premier tour que
c'est pâques malgré tout malgré 2 5e
mandat qui va s'annoncer ce que c'est
pas un peu décevant pour un sortant 56
pourtant avec seulement 36 % de
participation à peine plus d'un électeur
sur trois ici abordé les corps mais
hélas le phénomène vous le connaissez
bien
je crois qu'il ya encore des électeurs
qui ont eu peur bien évidemment d'une
contamination éventuelle
on l'a vu sur un électeur âgées qui
dépasse venus voter c'est valable au
niveau national je le regrette parce que
je crois que le monde municipal et par
définition de proximité qui a été
plébiscité y compris par la crise
sanitaire et ici aussi on a montré
l'exemple avec tous les bénévoles qui
m'entourent les colistiers et je pense
qu'on ait fait démocratiquement c'est
quand même mieux d'avoir des élections
où les électeurs viennent voter
après ça pour pas se plaindre dans tous
les cas pour beaune ils nous font
confiance ils ont retrouvé cette
confiance et ça nous va droit au coeur